uh 911 what's the St what's the state of
your emergency uh hey uh the tech
industry got flipped upside down over
the weekend I was staring at my phone
the whole time I haven't been so so uh
invigorated by any story in like five
years um my wife might divorce me
because I haven't looked up from my
phone I've just been on Twitter all
weekend Sam how are you doing right now
with this open AI story it's been
awesome I uh you the real winner through
all this is Twitter Twitter's been great
for this right Twitter just thrives
through all types of controversy tter
aka the Silicon Valley group chat has
been awesome awesome all weekend it's
been
[Music]
awesome I thought there was a chance
that you were just like out duck hunting
and I would come on today and you'd be
like what happened I'm a Sam Alman fan I
I've Loved this guy we've talked about
him for years I'm a big fan of his this
is and I love drama I love Gossip I read
TMZ every day and so now I've got TMZ on
Twitter it's awesome of course we're
talking about open Ai and Sam Alman
getting fired on we're recording this
Monday he was fired like Friday but
there's like news happening in real time
like constantly right exactly like uh
just as of an hour ago there's news so I
we don't know exactly where this is
going to all land we're going to try to
get this out as soon as we can uh we we
had a whole other episode planned today
we canceled it we just said Let's do
let's do this right now what's our
reaction what is our reaction to the
open AI stuff that's going on all right
Sam where do you want to I think we
should take this character by character
go through all the players that were
involved and I think we should give them
kind of a a grade and they can get you
know if they get an A or an A+ that
means they came out a big winner here
you can get a a c you can get an F I
think we should grade all the players of
how this has turned out for them in the
you know 48 hours so far that this
happened but do you want to First give a
little timeline summary recap yeah so I
think you should do it cuz even been
paying attention to it more closely but
it all started Friday at like what 3:00
exactly Friday
afternoon there's I get a text message
from Ben Levy he just says wow Sam
Balman what the [__] holy [__] what and
but he doesn't say the the news yet and
then I'm what and then he's like Sam
Alman out but he like misspells out then
he like does the Stars on out out of
what where is he out of it was
unfathomable that Sam Alman would get
fired right like uh and the same way
that you know I don't expect to wake up
and see that Elon Musk has been fired
from Tesla uh you don't think you don't
wake up and think that Sam alman's going
to get fired from open AI which is the
hottest private company probably the
most important startup in the world that
has gone from zero to 90 billion in
valuation in just a couple of years here
yeah it was shocking it started because
uh open AI at uh I don't even know our
guy puted this in military time so
what's this 248 at 248 open AI announced
a leadership transition they said that
Sam Alman is departing as CEO because he
was not consistently candid in his
Communications with the board and their
CTO uh a lady named Meera she was become
the intermittent uh CEO a little over an
hour later Sam Alman said I loved my
time at open AI it was transformative
for me personally and that he's excited
for what's next well let's pause there
because the first phase here is wild
speculation so the speculation is oh my
God shock and speculation so I can't
believe this happened like an April
Fool's joke it must have been something
bad dude you know he must be you know
this was there fraud um did they unleash
AGI was there a huge privacy like leak
uh that is causing him to have to step
down because there was a security issue
that he he overlooked is this there's
like this accusation from his sister
about sexual assault when they were kids
is it because of that and everybody
assumes it's got to be the worst until 1
hour later or when is it 1 hour later
yeah I think uh a couple hours later
Greg who was the the chairman and was
essentially his co-founder uh of open AI
the the lead technical guy at the time
uh or the early days sends this message
to the team hi everyone super proud of
what we built starting in my apartment
eight years ago we've been through tough
times and great times together
accomplishing so much doing what should
have been impossible based on today's
news comma I quit wishing you all the
best the eye lowercase lower
and um and so then now we're we enter
phase two phase two is wait Greg's on
the board wait Greg is a standup guy if
it was something really bad Greg would
not have just quit with him there must
this must not be as bad is there some
kind of power play jealousy a coup
that's happening here is Sam being wrong
and the instantly I see the court of
public opinion shift and the court of
public opinion says look if Sam did
something really effed up Greg would not
have just followed him out the door and
quit unless Greg was in on it so still a
possibility but more likely it seems
like Greg doesn't stand for this
reasoning so maybe we don't stand for
this reasoning and all of a sudden you
see the Sam Army come forward people who
are startups from YC when he was the
president of YC saying look uh I don't
know what happened here but Sam is like
he went to bat for me uh so many stories
came out that were all the same variety
I don't know if you saw these they were
all the same variety it was a startup
saying we had a time when we were
screwed I emailed Sam to be like hey
here's what's going on blah blah blah
Sam quickly replied with just something
like hey make sure you you know you're
communicating or like um you know just
do your best there's only what you can
control but behind the scenes he went to
war for us we found out later that he
called All of investors threatened to
dangle them over the balcony if they if
they screwed us and he saved our ass and
didn't even mention it that he was doing
that just in the background he went
through and like saved us and we found
out later that this was true so I don't
know what what happened here but you
know I ride with with Sam well an
equally big deal is one time I had a
customer service question and I dm'd him
and he replied and he solved it for me
so exactly and all a lot of it was he
replied fast he replied what he didn't
have to he vouched for us when he didn't
have to he he he did by the way that was
not a joke he reply to me like I had
like a air I couldn't figure something
out and I was like I'm just going to DM
Sam and he replied with like this the
the he he solved my problem but yeah the
guy seems like a great guy and his
brother comes out and says to all the
people that are gleefully hating today
please know you are betting against the
wrong guy okay so that kind of
foreshadows act two act two is the
weekend so Friday you get the crazy news
dump now the weekend you have news that
people start even inside the company
start to stand with Sam because they say
if there was something bad tell us what
it is you don't have to say it publicly
say it internally what does it mean he
wasn't
candidly consistent or consistently
candid with the board about what did he
lie what did he lie about how bad was it
uh you're taking our leader out our two
leaders out now um and wait who is the
board oh the board is like this
combination of of of of people who have
no they didn't build this they don't
even own equity in this but they're
deciding our future because the board is
basically one legit technologist this
guy Adam D'Angelo who who was the
co-founder CTO of of Facebook back in
the day and then he co-founded quora
after that so you have Adam legitimate
character in Silicon Valley and then you
have a bunch of other people that
nobody's ever heard of one of them is
like that actor's wife she's like a you
know an academic somewhere never had a
job Jo Gordon Le yeah exactly you know
the the guy from from inception you know
like great um the guy from inception not
Leonardo
DiCaprio that's the first and not even
him he's not the one on the board and
not even him
exactly so you got like you know you got
her you got a couple other characters
here um but nobody that is again no
equity no skin in the game and uh no
track record building or operating you
know complex companies so that seems a
bit weird they getting data and um
rumors come out Sam's going to have a
new company by Monday Sam and Greg are
going to create an open AI competitor by
Monday which is just like a pretty
badass threat to throw down and so once
the team starts to say they start to
tweet out these Emoji hearts saying I
basically I stand with with Sam I don't
know all the details but if you don't
come out with any details explaining why
you did this I'm I'm gonna probably
leave with Sam and so the board starts
scrambling and they start trying to
renegotiate with Sam to maybe bring him
back and his conditions are like cool
I'll come back y'all all got to resign
CLE and clear my name uh you got to
bring back Greg and uh we're going to
put a put a new board together that's
like the board of my
choosing the board doesn't want to do
all that and uh so they're kind of
stalling they're going back and forth he
goes back to the office with a guest
pass on his badge and he says this is
the last time I'll ever enter this
office with guest pass and then at the
last minute we hear the news the the
news come out it looks like Sam's coming
back and then Sunday night it hits
there's a new CEO in town EMT Shear my
former boss the former CEO of twitch is
now suddenly these the guy for opening
ey Sam is out he's in shock that that
was like you know what I thought was the
end and before I went to sleep thinking
okay we're going to record this pod I
thought that was the end emit releases
an announcement on Twitter saying
basically like hey hey I'm here here's
my 30-day plan um I wake up this morning
and there's more
news 600 of the 700
employees of open AI have signed a
petition saying if you don't bring Sam
and Greg back and all resign we're all
leaving 600 of
700 it was actually 500 as of 3:00 a.m.
and then it got to 650 as of uh as of
right before recording this that's
basically 100 people woke up and also
signed the pledge including by the way
the guy who was supposedly behind the
entire coup ilot the main technologist
the scientist who was the on the board
who who was the guy who sent Sam a
Google meet link and was like Hey can
you join this right quick and Sam's like
sure let me just pop out let me just get
my microphone and he pops on and then
gets fired the whole board is sitting
there and they executed his ass Ilia
comes comes out and signs the pledge and
says I'm sorry for what I did what and
he even tweets out he goes like I want
to get the band back together and make
it right I'm sorry yeah I I regret what
I did and you know try to write the
wrong and then on top of that before
before that that that thing happened sa
Nadella the CEO of Microsoft comes out
and says hey um we still support open AI
um
sure look forward to beating the new guy
ett which is just a really funny way of
putting it uh cuz apparently they were
not consulted and only told one minute
before the firing happened that or one
minute before the press release went out
that Sam was fired um so they were
blindsided even though they put they've
agreed to fund1 billion dollar into this
company and own 49% of it um and then he
says oh and good news Sam and Greg now
work for
Microsoft and this is just like the
ultimate Checkmate move um because Sam I
don't know if you know this but
Microsoft not only do they own
49% not only do they uh provide all of
the funding which open a requires to F
to to exist they could pull that at any
minute now uh because a lot of that
funding is in uh compute credits so
basic server credits um but not only
that they also have the license to to
all the technology they they have the
model the weights the INF they have
everything that they need to basically
hand Sam and Greg the new the like all
of the code you don't have to start from
scratch here you go and so uh in the end
they got everything they got everything
they wanted they got the team the
technology the money they got they got
everything the most interesting part of
all this though is the characters
because this is everyone keeps saying
this is succession in real life and it
is it's the it's one of the greatest
things that happened in Silicon Valley
in the last you know 15 years it's a
it's a beautiful storyline we thought
Sam bankman was a was a was a gift from
the gods in terms of podcasting this is
actually I think more interesting it's
not played out yet so the story is still
G to like keep going but let's talk
about the characters let's talk about
Sam Alman first we talked about him well
we've talked about him a ton but this
guy basically his background is he's
from St Louis my hometown give a shout
out to St Louis then he moved to Silicon
Valley to join Y combinator at the age
of like 19 or 20 he started a company
that had like mild success I think it
raised a fair amount of money and sold
for $50 million of which he walked away
with $5 million at the age of like 21
and using that $5 million he parlay that
into hundreds of millions by investing
in things like Airbnb Dropbox things
like that because he worked at White
combinator eventually becomes president
of white combinator at the age of 27 two
two quotes from uh from Paul Graham
about Tom Alin and remember Paul Graham
is somebody who uh invested in Dropbox
invested in Airbnb invested you know he
is seen the founders he knows everybody
in Silicon Valley he's met Mark
Zuckerberg he's met all these guys and
so for him to be be most impressed by
Sam Alman means something and he says
Sam Alman has it you could parachute him
into an Island full of cannibals and
come back five years later and he'd be
the
king that's the first one and then he
goes the second one he goes uh I met Sam
Alman many years ago when he was 19
years old he was a Stanford Dropout
which by the way Harvard or Stanford
Dropout is the number one resume Stan
that is the number one like item if you
go to Harvard to Stanford and you don't
drop out you have intentionally chosen
to not have the number one credential
you can have which is Harvard Dropout or
Stanford Dropout um so he says within
meeting uh within three minutes of
meeting him I remember thinking ah so
this is what Bill Gates must have been
like when he was 19 in three
minutes I don't know what SE Alla did in
three
minutes but I would love I would love to
know I am fascinated by people who are
special the kind of the freaks I love it
in sports but you can see it you could
see LeBron James at age 17 was like a
freak of nature yeah he had like the
equivalent of a 42inch vert you know
whatever he did it was like yeah it was
like an eighth grader dunking there's
another story that's kind of remarkable
I thought this kind of tells you about
this guy's character so Sam alman's gay
he came out when he was like 15 or 16 I
think you said something about he's from
your hometown St Louis there's some
story which is that he came out and not
only did he just come out as a teenager
which alone takes some bravery he then
like hosted like a pep rally or
something like that he went to John
Burrows so in St Louis where I'm from
every most all high schools are either
Catholic or some type of Christian
whatever and he came out with being gay
but he like went to a or I think he
created like a club some type of like
gay club and at a Catholic school
they're like no we're not we're not
about this and so I think he led like a
walk out like a school walk out that
takes a lot of like leadership yeah he's
very courageous guy and then but for
like the last 15 years pre-open AI he
was even though he was president of Y
commentator he was still a little bit
behind the scenes and even though that
he was running this huge incubator and
he's a powerful guy it still felt like
well why would Paul Graham say this
about this kid who still has yet it
still has unfilled potential a couple
years ago he starts working on open Ai
and then all of a sudden we're like oh
all right the guy was plotting and it's
it's he's played the long game now we
understand why everyone like looks up to
this guy and open ey open AI has B
basically taken over the tech industry
and went from zero to you know one of
the biggest companies in the world in
what five years or something like that
yeah exactly so he leaves the most
prestigious job in Silicon Valley which
is you know president of of YC dean of
Harvard dean of our Harvard he quits
suddenly because the nonprofit research
organization he co-founded you know he
felt like that was the right opportunity
and he did that suddenly it was
surprising I remember at the time I had
the thought I think I've said this
before here which is that uh I had the
thought like if Sam Alman just quit
being the president of YC to go join
open
AI how can I justify coming into to work
tomorrow like why would I not also go to
open AI whatever open AI is I knew
nothing at the time but all I knew is if
that one of the smartest guys in the
world went and did that um maybe I
should go do that too and honestly that
would have been the greatest career move
I ever made if I had done that because
uh you know open AI quickly you know
changed its structure from nonprofit to
becoming you know like a capped for
profit thing and uh became worth you
know nearly hundred billion dollar in in
a short period of time creating chat GPT
the fastest growing product of all time
to get to 100 million users faster than
any and let's go to his two partners
because when he started it there's a
bunch of weird stories that I don't that
aren't entirely out in the open but it
seemed like there was something where
Elon Musk funded the business or helped
fund the business at first he invested
$40 million and he also helped to
recruit and uh convince a few of Sam's
co-founders to join is that right that's
right so basically the when people say
okay great Sam's just he you drop him on
an island of cannibals he comes out king
okay cool but what's his skill what does
he do and basically it was like on
anything about strategy or
ambition uh this is what Paul Graham
said he said if there's if there was
ever a question on strategy or ambition
I default to what would Sam do and um
you know this PO gram he's like 20 years
older than Sam saying that so that's
kind of impressive so what did he do he
basically has a conversation with El
musk and the two of them had shared the
same belief which was that artificial
intelligence was going to be a big deal
that we would be able to one day realize
AGI which is artificial general
intelligence think about it as um you
know super intelligence when when uh you
know uh AI is generally smarter than
than humans and kind of everything that
we you know most of the things that we
try to do um so the they both said
that's also kind of scary because we
don't know what's going to happen on the
other side of AGI so we should fund
research in a nonprofit that will uh
study you know fund the research around
this so that we could safely create AGI
instead of having AGI that kills us all
like the movies so what Sam did was he
hosts his dinner in Palo Alta and you
know he gets Elon Musk there and he gets
a few other smart key people one of them
was this guy Greg who was at the time
the CTO of stripe which was before open
AI was the most impactful big startup in
the world so they gets a CTO he gets
this guy Ilia who's um like the lead
research uh scientist in AI at at Google
essentially he's the kind of like one of
the founding fathers of of of AI and
deep learning um and so they get a bunch
of these people around the table and
they basically Reed Hoffman is there and
they basically like we need to do this
Elon basically agrees to fund $40
million into the nonprofit so Elon puts
his money where his mouth is Sam uh you
know helps recruit put the whole deal
together puts bring the people together
on the way home Sam's like hey Greg let
me give you a ride back to San Francisco
so they drive back to San Francisco and
what Greg says what Sam says is the
first 30 minutes it's an hourong drive
from Palo Alto to San Francisco since
the first 30 minutes Greg just asked me
rapid fire like 150 questions then the
next then at the 30 minute point he goes
okay I've decided I'm going to do this
I'll quit stripe and I'll join open AI
um whatever this thing is that you're
creating I will join it um so the next
30 minutes they started making their
plan like okay what are the first things
we need to
which tells you something about Greg uh
to do again a crazy career move like
that to uh you know just have
independent mindedness and conviction
and something that quickly um and tells
you something about Sam's persuasiveness
and ability to like put this thing
together then uh what Elon says that he
recruited Ilia out of Google which was
very very hard to do and he says it's
the reason that him and Larry pagee
founder of Google don't talk anymore uh
you know he used to be friends with
Larry he used to famously Elon didn't
own a house for a period of time and he
would just crash at friends houses so he
would crash at Larry Page's house all
the time he says that they got into
arguments about Ai and that he was
really worried about Ai and Larry was
like Tech forward and was like no it's
going to be amazing and um and then he
says that you know he got pissed when
Larry called him a speciesist basically
like you are you're just all about
humans and Elon was like what the [__]
else am I supposed to be about are you
not that scares me even more I'm going
to create open AI now to like defend
against Google which owned Deep Mind the
number one player at the time and so uh
Elon basically poaches Elon and Sam
poach Ilia out of Google which took a
lot of money and a lot of persuasion I
believe to get him out and that he
becomes when he joins open AI the
research Community who worships this guy
basically followed and they got all the
top researchers to join and that is the
founding story of opening eye it's
that's amazing right I mean that I just
this is like drama movie drama [__] of
just that that dinner that drive home I
mean this is perfect we're going to have
to have Justin timberlink Star as one of
these guys and so this brings us to I
think the second character that we
should talk about this guy Greg who I
believe is the unsung hero in this whole
thing because Sam Alman is kind of like
the her he's the hero right he get he's
the the
CEO he gets backstabbed he gets wronged
he's the Martyr he he he had to to
suffer people come out and they're all
ing Sam insuring like it's like a
funeral for Sam on Twitter the other day
he's like oh I remember that once Sam
responded to my customer service request
like oh I was on a bike once and Sam you
know he he he moved over in the lane so
I could go by right like everybody was
just sharing their favorite Sam memory
and then nobody's really talking about
Greg Now Greg in my opinion shifted this
whole [__] thing because at first it
was like damn I don't know what Sam did
must have been horrible blah blah blah
as soon as Greg came out and was like yo
on this I quit and they're like Greg's
the number two he's on the board he was
the chairman of the board I think uh
they're like if Greg doesn't think this
was right I don't think it's right and
so Greg single-handedly like shifted the
perception The Narrative around this
whole thing uh and the board didn't
counteract that and so I think Greg was
the the real hero of this and then what
I did was there's some amazing blog
posts that anybody who's a real nerd
about this stuff if you just really love
kind of like the the lore the cannon of
of Silicon Valley you got to go read
this Greg has blog post up on his blog
about um about the early days of open Ai
and um I think he blogged the early days
of open AI last
week no this is eight years ago this
thing started a long time ago and he
talks about like they didn't have an
office he's like all right just come to
my apartment he's like here's the four
of us in our apartment he's like I
didn't know anything about machine
learning so I did two things number one
I asked asked Ilia what is the number
one textbook about machine learning I
bought it and I studied it religiously
he's like I read everything there was to
know about deep learning and machine
learning he goes and this is the former
CTO of stripe he's not like a
non-technical dude he's known as like
this incredible one of these 10x or 100x
engineers and uh he says I didn't know
anything about deep learning so I just
dedicated myself to go read you know
page one chapter one of the book and I'm
going to take notes and I'm going to ask
a ton of questions he goes two
while these guys were setting up their
research stuff I did everything else
like oh your back looks a little
uncomfortable you need a pillow oh you
guys thirsty I'll go get smoothies and
he's doing literally all the like intern
grunt work those first few months to get
them set up he's like and it basically
was an alternating between research
would do something then research would
get blocked and I would say oh What's
blocking you they're like ah it's taking
forever to run this training set or I
have to like organize this data and then
Greg would stay up all night and
basically like do the engineering
because people don't realize engineering
and coding is very different than AI
research and so he's he would do the
coding that would make the researchers
go faster and he built basically all of
the infrastructure so that researchers
could do great work and um and even with
GPT like there was a story like uh you
know they ran the model and the output
was kind of like ah like it was so so
and then Greg like locked himself in a
room for two weeks and he came out and
suddenly GPT worked and people were like
what the hell just happened he's like
out and you know I did that and so he
has these great blog posts and photos of
those early days that I thought was kind
of amazing so Greg was born in ' 89
which puts him around 34 years old now
he joined stripe in 2010 became CTO in
2013 so he was CTO of stripe when he was
about 24 25 years old and then he go he
left stripe to co-found open AI so he
was only 26 27 when he started working
on open AI it's pretty amazing these
guys are are freaks unreal it's wild
it's unreal and by the way what did you
give we you forgot to give a grade so
Sam malman he's going to win no matter
what in all of this I so I think he was
going to get like let's say a B+ right
he was going to get a B+ why because you
got fired you got backstabbed by your
own your own people that not not great
not a great thing to happen two they
haven't said what you did but you did
something right they weren't just going
to fire you for nothing so like uh you
did something we don't know what it is
known okay I can't give you an AP for
that uh it looked like he was going to
get the job back which would have been
great but then he didn't so ah it didn't
come it didn't didn't happen in the end
so even though you got some some support
from your team didn't happen until the
Microsoft thing happened which was
literally like imagine playing a game of
chess and you're like oh I think I got
this guy uh you know I have a five piece
to three Advantage here his Queen is out
and then you look up from the board and
he's holding you know a Glock to your
head and that's what happened to Ilia
here basically it's like he's now he's
at Microsoft they have the license to
all of the technology they have all the
training data in the world because guess
what 90% of computers are PCS that run
Microsoft that run you know Windows uh
he has all the funding in the world he
got paid I'm sure there's you know like
SAA had to bring uh Sam and Greg in
before the stock market open on Monday
just to kind of like not have this an
issue for Microsoft uh that they got
screwed here they put a bunch of money
into into a into a lame duck and so he
got everything he got the tech 600 of
700 people follow are saying they're
going to follow him there so he got the
team he got the money he got the funding
and he got it all in 48 hours and they
and they were basically like yeah
they're going to lead a new subsidiary
of Microsoft that's going to do open uh
that's going to do research on AI it's
like Oh you mean open AI part two so so
that now he has to walk away with an A+
right like you can't you can't knock
that and and he's he's got the good guy
label unless they come out with some new
information that that shows that he did
something effed up which something has
to come out there's only three options
in my opinion of how the story for Sam
ends option A is it's a it's an
unforgivable sin I think that that is
not likely but it is possible that what
he's did is just well you're done option
b is he goes back to open AI become CEO
I think that was more likely not going
to happen I I think but option C is he
stays at Microsoft and I think in a
decade or five years he becomes the CEO
of Microsoft which is now worth5
trillion dollar or something at that
point 2.7 trillion today yeah so he's
he's GNA turn out okay so now this other
guy Ilia he looks like a schmuck here so
he's he's a loser here he looks he looks
like IIA gets an F he gets an F there's
a little bit of likability with him
where it's like oh you're just a
brilliant SCI
artist turn who was who was uh you were
you were manipulated in here because
you're just a scientist and you don't
understand human interaction we he play
so we should explain one thing which is
what are the possibilities of what Sam
did that might put Sam in the wrong or
Illy in the right so there is what
you're calling the unforgivable sin
which I would say by the way not a great
track record of anything being
unforgivable but let's say the really
the bad personal stuff could be the
could be one reason why in which case I
would say that's a completely Fair
reason to remove him if they did an
investigation found out that that was
true that they're in the right for
removing him um that's defensible but
they just haven't said anything um
reason number two is uh safety concern
so Ilia is famously like the reason he's
doing this is literally he's worried
about AGI he doesn't want the world to
end and uh what initially people thought
was Sam says all the right things about
safety but also Sam is like a you know
capitalist he's a entrepreneur he's he's
he he's a he's a hard charging guy and
he's running forward here and maybe
they're saying slow down and he's saying
no we don't need to slow down and
they're saying Sam this is too risky and
he's saying no no no this is not risky
we got to move forward that's what it
looked like the situation was and it was
made Crazier by the fact that I don't
know if you saw this he did an interview
the day before and he said something
like this he said I've been lucky to be
in the room four times now the last one
was just a couple weeks ago where I saw
something that pushed the veil of
ignorance forward and the frontier of
techn technology to us and like he
pushed the veil of ignorance away and
the frontier of technology to us so
basically he's saying like there's been
like three or four mindblowing moments
you know about AI I've been lucky enough
to be in the room the last one happened
a couple weeks ago SED till you see this
it's going to stun people and so so some
people are like yo did they like create
the monster super intelligent like did
they create AGI you know has AGI been
achieved internally and he like randomly
posted on Reddit not long ago AGI has
been achieved internally as like a joke
I guess um so some people said maybe
they've stumbled into something and this
guy's going too fast and it's you know
like the scientists are you know around
the nuclear bomb saying no no no we got
to like destroy this thing or we got to
like slow down this is getting too crazy
that would have been the other reason
which would have been again defensible
especially given that open AI Charter is
specifically says we're not about
increasing shareholder value we are
about you know safely building AGI to
benefit all of humanity so that is their
Charter and if they thought this guy's
moving too fast putting that at risk I
would say they are completely in the
right to do so if they believe that to
be true the bad part is again they've
come out with no evidence that that that
is the case they haven't explained
themselves so nobody believes them that
that's true uh the third reason so you
know you have the really bad thing you
have the safety argument and the third
thing is essentially it's just a power
play they're annoyed by him they don't
feel like he listens they feel like he's
getting all the credit or he wants Fame
and Fortune and Power Play Let's Get
this guy out of here and we will we get
to run and own this thing and that's
like a jealousy driven thing and I don't
know which of those is the most true I
don't know what you think but uh you
know it seems
like you know none of those are perfect
explanations I think
I I'll say what I think maybe later but
I it's number three I think I think it's
number three um let's talk about let's
let's come back to the board but let's
talk about emit she because you are one
of the handful of people or you know
however many people who have had a
relationship with him and understand and
so last night at 1:00 a.m. uh EMT
basically said I've been the guy that's
been picked he put out this really good
tweet where he explained what he was
doing the funniest part I thought was
he's had the job now for 12 minutes and
he did a wonderful job of saying the
word r he goes our products are going to
be this our team is going to do this we
are going and it reminded me of that
Meme where there's a guy who go he goes
hey I made this and he hands it to a
stick figure and the stick figure goes
you made this and then the first guy
leaves and the stick figure looks at the
thing that and he goes I made this and
it's the whole point about on the
internet where where people steal stuff
I actually think emt's a great guy so
I'm I'm just I'm just messing around but
I thought it was amazing how he's like
12 minutes later this our company's
going to do this what do you think about
EMT in this role um he he's been getting
a lot of criticism because he previously
shared online that he's like I actually
think we need to slow things down and
and bunch of people are like this is
ridiculous don't slow down whatever but
he seems like a really thoughtful great
CEO am I wrong so emit uh you're right I
worked with him for about two years got
to sit with him you know in hundreds of
meetings and see you know how he thinks
and you know hang out with him have
beers and just kind of talk to him he
came on the podcast I talked to him for
an hour there about uh AI stuff you
always said he was really thoughtful
he's extremely intelligent in a broad
way so uh most people are not that
intelligent that you meet you meet some
people that are like you know oh they're
like above average then you meet some
people as you say the oven Burns hotter
and it's just very clear like he's just
got more horsepower in his head than
most people I think that's great I think
you know uh as much as we like to say
that like hard work is what matters like
yeah you know what also matters like uh
intelligence is also really a really
strong attribute it's like you know like
yeah um you know Steph Curry's got great
skills but like LeBron is 68 250 right
like it you know size and speed matter I
hate when people downplay intelligence
and I'm like guys let's just admit some
people are born smarter just like some
people are 7et tall there's a reason why
20% of Americans who are 7et tall and
below the age of 30 are in the NBA you
you just you're better you're better at
that particular
thing way that height helps you with
basketball intelligence helps you with
running companies right like that that's
a thing uh so Ean is extremely
intelligent he is amongst the most
intelligent people I've ever met um so
that's the that's the first thing uh
second thing is he's got depth and
breadth so a lot of people are really
really intelligent in one specific
domain it seems like this guy Ilia might
be one of those where he's just
extremely extremely technically
intelligent but it seems like in the
game of you know uh soft power and
politics and and uh you know uh people
and and all that he you know had a
pretty boneheaded way of doing this that
didn't didn't work out to his own tweet
I deeply regret what I did it was
handled very poorly so you know I think
he you know some people could really
really smart in one technical domain but
they're not don't have a breath of of
intelligence um I would say that EMT is
wide and deep so he's technically very
strong he was a great engineer they
built twitch one of the you know the
best live streaming products and it was
him and this guy Kyle Kyle went on to
build self-driving cars and EMT ran
twitch for like whatever 18 years or
some [__] like that um so you know
between Justin TV and twitch and so uh
he's very good technically which is
important because it's a deeply
technical product he you know he said to
me the other thing one thing when I was
talking about AI he's like he's like
yeah like once you understand how
Transformers work and I was like well
let's stop there because I have no idea
how Transformers work so like the rest
of your sentence because he said it like
yeah it's easy I mean just once you once
you get out Transformers work it's like
you know blah blah blah blah just
anybody could go watch a video we've had
a smart a couple smart people in this
pod and I'm they triy to use analogies
because I'd be like I don't understand
what you're saying and they' use an
analogy and I'm like can you please use
use an analogy for your analogy like I
think we had biology on here and he was
like referring to the battle of the
river of TS in World War II in order to
like describe crypto and I'm like guy I
don't know what the battle battle of Tam
was like this doesn't make sense to me
right right exactly you know I'm asking
for a lunch bowl over here and you're
making Gourmet like let's let's do this
right what what's his soft skills like
well his soft skills I I would say when
I experienced him which was like you
know whatever he's been he had been
running the company for over a decade as
CEO uh I thought he was good not great
so for example I think he always knew
what to do like if you caught him when
he was calm he would give great advice
on the people's side of how to handle
something however In the Heat of the
Moment he was prone to Falling it
falling into like debates about
semantics about words about data that
would make people feel like [__] and he
would like win the battle and lose the
war type of thing with people and so I
don't think he was great with that but I
also think twitch was like a bunch of
very like kind of it was a community
product with a bunch of very like sort
of woke people at in the company that
were like very touchy feel about stuff
uh you know I think open AI is going to
be his type of people you know like EMT
was better in meetings where all the
people were engineers and product
product people he was worse the more
that the people were you know um we got
legal PR coms you know marketing you
know those meetings went worse for him I
thought and so I think he'll have less
of that here uh but he also is like
apology like he'll reference the Battle
of the Bulge like he'll reference you
know uh well the judicial system in
Ireland
back in the 1500s what they did was
really interesting it's like dude why do
you know this he's like well I've read
up on all the Judicial Systems I was
very interested in how how governing has
changed over time it's like that's your
casual reading he's like yeah like I
just I I don't know is that not is that
weird and it's like you know somebody's
really good when they when they don't
even realize it's weird when the thing
they do is like really [__] weird and
so uh he's has a very very wide set of
knowledge now he's getting kind of uh
labeled as a uh a desel I don't know if
you've seen this like a deceleration
meaning like somebody wants to slow
things down because as soon as he got
named suit yeah kind of like a suit or
like a Doomer um you know like oh this
is this guy's anti- technology which is
pretty silly and it's like you know if
he could be technology he would you know
like he he's a technologist through and
through they're calling the guy who
invented twitch a boomer basically yeah
uh it's stupid and so um you know a
friend who a mutual friend described it
well they go because people dug up all
his old tweets and he said if if an open
if opening is at a 10 right now in terms
of speed you know it should probably be
at like a one or two because uh you know
you just don't want this cat to get out
of the bag and so um I want to read you
what he uh I have the transcript of what
he said on our podcast which when he
came on about AI so I asked him very
simply I said is AI going to kill us all
and he goes maybe I I go it's
interesting you say maybe it's going to
kill us all cuz like you're pretty like
Pro technology and everything you're an
optimist and he goes well it's because
I'm an optimist that I'm scared if I was
pessimist if I was like oh this AI
thing's overhyped is technolog is not
that impressive it's just a nice little
magic trick it's but it's nothing real
underneath it if I was pessimistic I
would be less worried I'm optimistic I
am extremely impressed with how these
work and I see a pathway where this is
going to get better very fast and at
some point it's going to be able to
self-improve that's very scary CU we
don't know what happens on the other
side of that it's because I'm optimistic
then the second thing he said was he
goes here's the analogy uh you know in
biology there's like there's now like
ways that you can synthetically do
things you can we know we can edit genes
for example and we can like add an extra
leg to a sheep or we can like modify a
virus this was like you know Co right
like you could modify a virus and make
it more uh spreadable and we all saw
with Co how dangerous that capability is
that like this thing you know if this
leaked from a lab that's really really
bad like you know that that was a big
mistake that technology made that like
you know [__] up the world for a few
years and so he's like you know we have
regulation I think everybody kind of
agrees we should maybe not go super fast
and make it easy for somebody to like
print small pox in their home right like
we should maybe not give that capability
to everybody and maybe we should like
slow down to make sure there's some
oversight to we so that we don't do
something really bad that like creates a
super virus he's like people get that
when it comes to biology they don't
really get that when it comes to AI he's
like with a a I uh here's the thing AI
is really good at like the one thing you
need in order to be really good at AI at
developing AI he's like AI can code it
can write code it can read everything
there is to know about a subject in an
afternoon become absolute World expert
at it and then it can translate that
into action it can it translate into
writing code it could also design chips
yeah it doesn't do either of those two
things perfectly right now it's not it's
not amazing at writing code um and it's
not amazing at designing chips but it
can do them it's it's within the zone of
things that AI can be good at the type
of things that AI can be good at which
means that over time it's going to be
able to write code that designs Ai and
write uh you know and design chips that
make AI better and once that thing can
improve itself it's going to get fast
it's going to get really amazing really
fast faster than anyone can expect and
maybe that's a good thing maybe it all
works out but also maybe it doesn't and
that's like he's like even if I think
the probability of a really bad thing
happening is low
it's the consequences are so bad we're
not just talking about like a virus
that's kind of like screws up your
computer or like gets like you know even
like a pandemic that gets people sick
we're talking about this could destroy
like he says like we could destroy all
of the value with the light cone which I
don't even know what the light cone is
but I don't want that um right so he's
describing like even if it's low
probability we should just be really
really careful about that and like make
sure we don't screw the whole thing up
um and a friend
reach out at one thing they go they go
everybody saying like emt's gonna want
to like slow this down and stop it he's
like no no emt's smart EMT knows the the
game theory of this the prisoners
dilemma if you go too slow somebody else
will create AGI before you because you
you slow down to zero so somebody else
will get there before you who may not
share your moral beliefs around safety
so you can't go too slow where other
people get their first who don't share
your your safety views but you can't go
so fast that you don't actually build to
safely there's a Middle Ground to seek
and so um and I think that's the best
description of this where people are
trying to label him as one thing and
knowing what I know about him that's
just not true well let's go like through
Rapid Fire of like some other story
points we and we'll make that quick and
then also we've been there of what we
think will is going to happen one quick
story point for you if you like we got
to do final grades before we do stories
final grades so the the board what do
you what you graded the board oh they're
[__] losers so the worst they they
look horrible they're going to get you
got an like and it stands for [__]
loser yeah yeah is there an NFL they're
the worst I mean it doesn't matter what
the truth is it's all about perception
and they look like the worst uh
including uh uh Adam D'Angelo the
founder of Kora right now he looks
horrible uh so F they get an F do you
agree yeah agreed uh EMT what do you
give EMT he's uh 12 minutes onto the job
here
tbdc he uh he's actually actually it's
actually like a d or a c at the moment
he's getting dragged I think uh which is
fair but no he he looks like he's a
loser here because of
perception right um and what about he's
taking the hero's job like it's it's
hard to look good regardless of how
amazing he is right right uh and what
about SAA
Microsoft um he gets a b he looks pretty
good I mean he he's he's the man I mean
he's kind of made a Resurgence for Saia
or for Microsoft I think that um I think
there's a real world where Bing actually
catches up to Google in terms of search
and and uh Microsoft is going to become
just an even bigger company than they
they already are so yeah I mean he's A's
him and Sam are the masterminds I got to
give him an A+ the dude you know
mobilized over the weekend and before
the markets opened and could hit
Microsoft stock he had basically
acquired open AI for negative $100
billion he Aqua hired open AI which is
incredible and so now he got open AI out
of the nonprofit capped profit structure
it's just super for-profit inside
Microsoft he got the key Talent you know
Sam Greg all of the key people 600 of
the of the key people
um and now they just own the whole thing
instead of
49% like that's that's an A+ he crushed
it on this one um he he's the man um so
let's do let's do the story lines yeah
here's one quick storyline have you
heard of um Fairchild conductors do you
know what that is I've so I've heard of
it but I'm not a history guy so what's
the story there's isn't there something
like the the traitorous eight or
something what what is that yeah so so
basically there was the there was a big
company called uh I think it was called
Shockley conductors and they made
conductors uh computer chips in the 60s
in Silicon Valley people were pissed off
at the guy who owned it William chaky I
think his name is he was brilliant but
just a pain in the ass and so these
eight guys said hey you got to bail or
we're bailing and the guy the CE goes
see and so these eight people went and
started Fairchild which was basically um
the equivalent is like Nvidia but back
then in 19 basically birthed Silicon
Valley right that was like the that was
the seed round of Silicon Valley yeah
and they were F their culture was famous
because they were casual so it was like
where nerds could come and be casual and
where like the best actually best ideas
actually won and that was where the
whole like culture of Sila Valley uh
arguably started there and then the off
offshoot of fair child conductors was
basically uh IBM so IBM was founded by
one of the founders of Fairchild um uh
Andy Grove the guy the famous manager of
I think he was the CEO of IBM he came
from there U the founders of seoa
capital uh Kleiner and Perkins I think
might have spun out I mean like B
basically it was there's just all these
people but uh the story of the
treacherous eight is what they're called
is very similar to this story and so if
you're interested in this type of uh
like stuff and you and you could
actually go and read that book and you
could see a lot of similarities between
what is going on now so this is like our
version of that and so it's going to end
well I think for Greg and Sam because I
it ended really nicely for the the
treacherous eight um so that's an
interesting by the way my prediction is
that they they unwind this whole thing
and they revert back to open AI by the
way that's my like is it hasn't happened
yet but I think the final step now now
that Ilia signed the pledge being like I
quit and I'm also going to go work there
it's like what is the point of even
having the open AI entity if 600 of the
people including all of the leaders are
gone um I don't think they want to be
inside Microsoft necessarily so I think
what's to happen is I think this was the
final straw and by the end of I bet by
the end of day today uh they get a
whoopsy daisy undo on the whole thing
and uh Sam is back as CEO of open Ai and
uh they just the board quits and they
get a new board that's my my prediction
by the way I think doesn't make I
believe I believe that that prediction I
think is the same I think there's long
predictions here which is new startups
aren't going to want to have board of
directors um I actually think that's the
wrong takeaway Brian hallan from HubSpot
he wrote he's like no the takeaway
shouldn't be not have a board the
takeaway should be have a good board um
and I think so but I think that
potentially like the governance
structure of companies might actually
change significantly because people are
going to be like uh they're going to
they're going to have PTSD from just
hearing the story and that actually is
going to have Downstream effects that
are quite large and and
in a weird way it could even impact like
the Venture Capital industry I think
that is um a real possibility I totally
agree and I think it's so stupid so
right now there's so many startups that
are reading their their governing
documents about the board and thinking
through do I need to change my
board here's my public service
announcement don't worry bro you're not
open AI you're not Sam Alman and uh your
board is also not these Schmucks either
and nobody cares and like you know the
for a startup like don't worry about
your governance structure right now like
you should be doing these standard
vanilla things of you know put competent
people there and then don't worry about
it too much like you need product Market
fit you don't have this problem in the
same way that like when you hear what's
going on with like Uber or Facebook it's
like you're not Uber and Facebook you
don't have the same problems that they
have don't suddenly start spending your
energy over there and take your eye off
the actual main problem that you need
product Market fit you need growth I
think the the takeway here is open ai's
board was stupid I that was actually a
strategic mistake it seems like on Sam
alman's part also I think the whole
nonprofit stick that was stupid too um
TBD if that if I'm going to be right on
that but as of now it's look it would
have been a lot simpler maybe if this is
just a board or this is just a normal
board where they have Equity started
with a good board they started with Elon
Musk and Reed Hoffman and all these like
legit players on their board and then by
one they all quit so basically like Elon
quit cuz things weren't like they
weren't listening to him and he took his
ball and tried to run home uh Reed
Hoffman quit because he started a
competitor another guy quit because he
wants to run for president another
person quit it's like basically five of
the original board members quit for
different reasons either starting
competitors or conflict of interest or
uh running for president or whatever and
um this is what they got left with yeah
so hopefully that gets changed um what
are any other takeaways I think um what
were you saying about this was the best
and the worst of us yeah that was kind
of my big picture takeaway like I feel
like this was the best of Silicon Valley
and the worst of Silicon Valley all in
the same weekend um you know the best I
thought was things like you know what
Greg did when he was like yo I'm out too
I quit even though they tried to they
they wanted to retain him they weren't
firing him it's like yeah that's a real
co-founder right that's that's a that's
a ride or die sort of ducks fly together
moment and I thought that was uh that
was badass I thought that was the best
of us and then I thought the worst of us
was like this like stupid board that has
no skin in the game that doesn't know
how to communicate that didn't like
handle this well just fumbling and
bumbling and removing a Founder from
their removing basically the greatest
founder alive you know outside of Elon
Musk from their company that they
created for what seems like no reason
and if there is a reason you got to like
say it and even if you say it in a way
that wasn't like doesn't get you sued
like you know maybe that's why they're
not saying anything but you have to at
least tell your team you have to give
more than what they did uh they handle
it better than what they did um and if
it was so bad then don't negotiate with
him to come back right like if it was
that bad then he shouldn't have 24 hours
later been in discussions to come back
um you know so the board I thought was
you know was the worst of us I thought
you know Twitter was alive and popping
and it really did feel like it was the
Silicon Valley group chat that was kind
of the best of us and the worst worst of
it was like you know it felt like Gossip
Girls all weekend and um that's kind of
lame and there's a bunch of you know
like speculation wasted energy and you
know like I saw these Twitter spaces
going on for hours and hours of people
just like discussing like you know it
was a real housewives episode and they
can't believe that Jenna said that right
like it just seemed like you know it
wasn't it seemed like gossip and I
thought that was a waste of time you
know I thought there was a whole bunch
of things that were kind of like the
best and the worst showed themselves in
the same weekend you know maybe um you
know it could be that there actually is
a legitimate you know crazy safety
concern concern and like this guy was
going too fast and you know this Ilia
guy was maybe the hero and was pumping
the brakes even though it screwed up
their his own economics if he really was
standing for something he believed in
right like it could be that it was that
or it could be that it was a jealousy
power play and and take him out right we
don't know but I just thought there was
a whole bunch of best and worse another
one was like just this instant labeling
like these like tribes like I don't know
if you've seen this like e
slac thing is that the E cell and D cell
yeah basically this
there's a whole bunch of people in the
Twitter bio that have EAC I've been
seeing this for months I have no idea I
didn't even know what the hell this was
but it's except you're an effective
accelerationist right so it's basically
like kind of a play on the effective um
uh Al or whatever altruism that s
bankman freed was doing that's pretty
stupid I think the one is basically like
pedal to the metal uh you know Tech
forward progress forward technology
Optimist uh and it's like that's the
cool Club to be in and then anybody
who's like saying hey slow down you're a
Dell which is like you know um it's the
dword basically it's a it's a slur it's
an insult and to me this was again it's
the worst of us it's the it's like
people in Silicon Valley make fun of
politics like oh I'm not left or right
it's not that simple it's not Republican
Democrat I'm not I don't fall into these
stupid party you know tribes that are
just blindly you know following the herd
and it's like we're doing the same thing
uh this eel D cell [__] is the same
thing as Democrat Republican R blue left
right um it's a
oversimplification of um a massive over
oversimplification of what's going on
and so I thought that was kind of the
worst of us too final prediction my
prediction is in the next 24 hours all
this is going to be undone and things
will be back to normal that's my
prediction is that yours too I maybe
we'll give it 48 hours but I think at
this rate 24 hours when I was in second
grade my class had a field trip and um
they said they told the parents they
said hey you need 20 bucks to come to
this field trip so my mom gives me $20
in the morning and I go and I'm excited
about the field trip I don't think I'd
ever been on a field trip think was my
first and uh they're like hey okay put
your thing over here sign your give me
your signed waiver and put your 20 bucks
and I'm like looking around I'm like
where did my 20 bucks go I was right
this is my desk it's not here I'm
looking under the table on the desk I
check my backpack I'm like what the hell
somebody took my 20 bucks I can't go on
the field trip now and so I go to the
teacher and I'm like
Miss like uh somebody stole my $20 and
she's like oh my God like stealing
that's the stealing money from a kid
like that's not okay and she's like are
you sure I'm like yeah I was right there
and so uh she turns the world upside
down she starts she's like hey Blows the
Whistle she's like everybody sit
down who has the money and it's just
silence nobody raises their hand and
she's like okay we'll try this a
different way I'm going to put a jar
outside and we're going to walk out one
by one and I want the $20 to be in the
jar by the time this done no harm no
foul everybody walks out everybody walks
in she comes back jars empty and she's
pissed now she's like okay I gave you a
chance to do this clean I gave you a
chance to do this publicly now we're not
going on the field trip guys guess what
and uh and I'm like oh my God this is
like getting the field trip cancelled
this is crazy not just for our class she
tells the teacher next door she's like
we don't earn we didn't earn this
because there's been you know one of our
core values has been betrayed here and
where was the
$20 and then I'm like I got to go to the
bathroom and I get I get up I'm like
Miss can I go to the bathroom she's like
yeah sure I get up and I feel this like
scratchy feeling in my sock oh and I'm
like I reached down and I'm like [__] I
put I put the 20 bucks in my sock this
morning that's right I just
remember but here I am like a drug
dealer dude what are you do here I am
and now I'm like what do I do I'm like
the class is going to be so mad at me if
they realize this is in my sock the
whole time the teacher's going to be so
mad at me if she realizes that I
accidentally did this I didn't mean for
all this to
happen and so I went to the restroom I
took the 20 bucks put it in the toilet
and I flushed the toilet I went back to
my
seat did you really did you really do
that is that really how that ended no
that made for better better but I did
hand it to her and she laughed it off
and then we went on the field trip but I
thought it' be a better story the other
way but that thing did happen with the
sock and it wasted half of the field
trip day and uh that's how I feel Ilia
feels right now where he's like I did
not mean for all this to happen like
this got way bigger than I thought this
was going to get and uh whoops can I
just like give you this 20 bucks we
pretend this never happened and that's
what he's trying to do right now and uh
you know power to him I I've been there
I feel
you all right well we're going to see
what happens um that's the pod